well the consequences of lockdowns in
wealthier countries are also felt much
further away
that's because migrants who normally
send money back to families in their
home countries
have less work and thus less descend
these remittances as they're called are
no small sum
they amounted to more than half a
trillion u.s dollars
in 2019 worldwide that amount shrank
noticeably last year
as lockdowns bid in in the wealthy world
again limiting migrant work
the world bank believes this year will
see even less money sent home
and that could mean even more families
falling into poverty in places like
sub-saharan africa
remittances there totaling 48 billion in
2019
nearly half of that roughly 21 billion
dollars going to nigeria
alone now for more on this i'm joined by
dw correspondent in nairobi joy doreen
bira joy good to see you um what exactly
does this effect have when there are
fewer remittances going to africa
what what is the overall effect that you
see
so african countries partly depend on
remittances from the diaspora to develop
the economy so it is basically part of
the
budgetary planning for economies on the
african continent and so
the fall in remittances in countries
like nigeria would largely affect the
economy because nigeria is largely
dependent on
minerals mineral resources and oil
the prices of crude oil dropped last
year which affected its budgetary
allocations and so
that coupled with a drop in remittances
was definitely grave on the economy but
countries like kenya
registered a shop rise in remittances in
the year 2020.
okay so not everyone following that
trend that we've seen um
what are the prospects for migrant
workers in their host countries in terms
of
getting vaccines for example getting
back to work
getting vaccines would largely depend on
the working conditions for them as
migrant workers
in those host countries because uh maybe
i don't know if for some of the wealthy
countries they're going to need that
or they're going to have a condition
that for people to go back to work they
should be vaccinated that is really
going to depend
on the working conditions in particular
countries
but in terms of how it's going to affect
their remittances back home
that is likely going to happen this year
because the world bank as well has
predicted that
remittances are likely to fall 7.5 in
2021.
joy briefly what can african countries
do to make up for that loss in money is
there anything
it's really very little that can be done
i don't know if probably they could
boost the
migrant workers conditions if they can
but that's going to be a hard one really
for african economies
but they can try to look into other
areas of revenue generation
outside of the diaspora remittances
hopefully
uh to generate some more income to boost
all right joy during beer in nairobi
thank you